Ellie definitely would have sacrificed
himself like to her that's her purpose
like that's the reason that she's alive
I don't think she'd even think twice she
would she would do it every time
Bella Ramsay is with us right now yes
Bella Ellie herself Bella thank you so
much for joining us today well of course
thank you for having me and I my cat is
joining you can't see him because it's
quite dark but he's gonna be a part of
this because he is incredibly old
incredibly needy pets are welcome pets
are welcome on the last of pots it ends
in both the show and the game with Joel
lying to Ellie like I get why he did it
and he says I swear and Ellie's like
okay and they go to they go to you know
live with Tommy in the show in your
opinion it being Ellie in that moment
does Ellie believe him what what is she
thinking I don't think Ellie does
believe him like at her core I don't
think she does but she has to force
herself to believe him enough to because
it's their thought of him
it not being true is too painful uh so I
think that she like forces herself to
to believe him and like buys into her
own delusion because
he has to for her own sanity uh but I
think deep down she's always had a
feeling what do you think because during
the show she's like wanting to help
people so much she like rubs her blood
on Sam but then she also thinks that
they're just gonna take her blood and
find a cure she doesn't really know that
their plan is like we have to kill this
girl in order to find this cure what do
you think Ellie would have done given
her own choice in the matter do you
think that she would have sacrificed
herself Ellie definitely would have
sacrificed himself like to her that's
her purpose like that's the reason that
she's alive like as soon as she found
out the news that she was immune and
like possibly held the key to to
providing a vaccine for the world like
that's when she felt for the first time
that her life mattered so I think that
the idea that would be taken away from
her is it's not even on the card to her
like given the choice I don't think
she'd even think twice she would she
would do it every time
yeah
okay what has been your favorite
reactions to the show so far I'm very
well I have like it's like a a gay army
you were like super on Twitter who are
just like supporting me and Ellie and
it's like they're so much louder than
any people who still hate it or hate the
show like the homophobic trolls whatever
and it's just like that feels nice to
just have like that Army but I mean
that's been a reaction that I've really
enjoyed I like I love um Gamers
reactions to the show like that's the
thing that feels the most validating is
when like Gamers beloved uh uh Gamers
you are so invested in the game to then
say like this is so good and like lives
up to my expectations and exceeds them
like that's the thing that's the
reaction that feels
like really really cool have you seen
it's like the meme it's it's Joel and
Ali in the game and Joel's wearing a
shirt that says I love my lesbian
daughter
oh yeah that's my favorite oh and
actually you know to answer your
question better like it's all the memes
that have come out of it oh the the meme
reactions that people are doing like
there was one the other day that I loved
um after the episode seven where it's
like Ellie game Ellie has her hands in
her head and she's like I'm so gay
um and I I just love them I love people
like rehashing game the game memes to
like react to the show has any any of
the episodes stood out to you as like
memorably challenging emotionally to get
through what has been the toughest one
for you to like look at and be like wow
Ellie's got to go through this I have to
perform this episode 8 for sure it's
it's the most intense like it's Ellie
surviving without Joel and surviving for
Joel and enduring so much pain for him
um yeah and it was pulled like it was
emotionally and physically this was like
the toughest episode uh for sure it's
definitely a like she's experienced
traumas before but like this is like
nothing that she's ever experienced I
don't think she ever anticipated like of
all the things that could have gone
wrong in this world like all the time
she could have died up until now like
she did not
anticipate this
um I think she is also scared not only
of like what happened with with David
and and what was what he was going to do
to her but she's also I think maybe more
afraid of what she did to him and that
violence that lives within her I don't
think that she's wait we see how it
actually punch Bethany in the face in
the last episode and like we've seen her
be violent but not like this and I think
that's that
guess her like what she's capable of
like she killed David probably within
like the first two hacks of the ax to
his face and she just kept going and
kept going and kept going and it felt
good
um in the same way that like when Joe
was beating that guy to death it was
like he didn't have to do that yeah I
don't know it's a lot but I loved it
like I had a great time
um but yeah it was I remember reading
the script and I actually have videos of
me reading the script for the first time
because I was so it's a sort of a Funny
Story I was really concerned that my
American accent wasn't American anymore
because I'd like got so used to it so
it's like I'm gonna record myself
reading this episode out loud so that I
can listen back and see if I sound
American and then it just turned into me
like life reacting to them the crazy
that I was reading and uh I have them
somewhere I I dread I don't think I can
ever watch them back but I remember the
first time I realized reading the script
that like these guys were cannibals I
was like what it was yeah
I want to see those yeah if you don't
want to watch them we will
maybe one day I know you guys are all
you guys are all wrapped up on season
one and season two renewal we're all so
excited to hear about are you like how
did how do you get ready to go back to
work and do this again are you what how
are you feeling about that I'm really
excited uh it it still feels surreal to
me that it's gonna
go again
um but also I'm going into it with the
ex like I don't want to go into it
comparing it to the uh experience the
first season because I'm like that
that's never gonna like season one of
The Last of Us was like the best year of
my life and it's not gonna be the same
so I just have to like go into it being
like this is season two and I loved
season one but this is just gonna be
different
hmm